معكم مجددا في البيت الابيض لقد قضينا وقت
طويلا في الهاتف وفي الفيديو ولكن من
الجيد ان اراك شخصيا موجوده معنا اننا
بالفعل كنا على اتصال منذ بدايه هذا
الصراع وهذا النزاع وهذا يختلف عندما تكون
متواجدين لانه بطبيعه الحال خلال هذه
الازمه هذه الازمه اهم هذه الازمه قد
الهمشى الشعب الالكتروني والشعب الامريكي
هذا هو سبقكم الاول منذ شهر في ابراهيم
وان الرئيس
الاطفال والمدارس التي تهاجم هذا شيء غير
مسموح به لقد
من المهم بالنسبه للشعب الامريكي وكذلك
بنسبه للعالم برمته ان يستمع اليكم ليعرف
ما هو الانذال في اوكرانيا
واهميه ان تعمل جميعا وان نعمل معكم في
هذا هو اليوم 3
بها بروتين بغاره جده همم
300 يوم حيث
الشعب الاكراني يعاني يعاني الكثير
فان الشعب الاوكراني اود ان اتوجه اليه
واقول له بانه
على شجاعه وكذلك موقفه القوي
والتصديه
لسياسه الامبرياليه لروسيا التي تعتبر
بانه بامكانها ان تفرد نفسها بالقوه وفي
الواقع فانكم انتم لستم وحدكم لكم الكثير
من الدعم ولن تكونوا ابدا وحدكم بين حريه
اوكرانيا هي مهدده حتى اليوم فان الشعب
الامريكي همم هذا الشاب لن يتردد لتقديم
الدعم لكم لكم
والامريكان وكدهون الامريكان
سيخسرنا لكم الامكانيات وذلك لا يمكنكم ان
تعمل بطريقه موحده وتق حكم الدعم الدائمه
الشعب الاوكراني فان الشعب الاخراني يقوم
بنضال وكفاح والشعب الامريكي يعلم بانه
يجب ان نضع حد ان لهذه الهجمات التي تمس
الحريه وسلامه واذا فعل ذلك لم نحترم
السياده العامه والا فان العالم سيصلك
تتجاه عندما ارسل همم
اوكرانيا فان الشعب الامريكي كان على
استعداد
لان يتدخل
ونحن بهذا ما فعلناه حتى قبل بدايه الغزل
فان تهديدات بروتين ضد او الكلام حيث
لكن لم نفع ذلك لوحدنا فمدوا البدايه
فالولايات المتحده انضمت مع حلفائها عبر
العالم وذلك تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا
وهكذا فلقد حددنا عقوبات غير مسبوقه ضد
روسيا وسيكون من الصعب
لروسيا ان تواجهها كل ذلك هناك اكثر
وكذلك
المنظمات الدفاع الجوي كلها موجوده
همم
الخدمات الاساسيه
مثل
التربيه وكذلك موظفين في المجال الصحي
واكثر من مليار من دولارات ستخصصوا قال
دعم للشعب الاوكراني ولقد خصصنا ذلك في
البنك الدولي وكان همم وهذه هذا الغاز جعل
الملايين من القنينه يغادرون بلدهم وتركوا
همم
بيوتهم واننا
نستقبل قد استقبل كثير
وعاملنا ايضا الى الجانب الحلفاء وهذا
يدخل في ايطاليا
واننا لقد
خلصنا اكثر من 174
الى الماء الصالحي للشرب وكذلك الخدمات
الصحيه وهمم كذلك لمساعده الاوكرانيين في
موسم الشتاء نحن وشركاؤنا نقدم الكثير من
الدعم وهمم
[موسيقى]
سنواصلوا تقديم هذا الدعم لاوكانيا فان
الوكالين قد فلحوا فازوا في معركه
بكل قوه
الغزو الروسي السيد الاسكي لقد تسرفتم
بطريقتين واضحه فلقد همم وصلتم
الطريق السلام وانتم ومنفتحون يا سلام
عادل ونحن نعلم بانوتيلا
هذه الحرب والولايات المتحده التزم بان
تسمح لي الشع الاوكراني باني اجي واصل
الدفاع عن بلده ضد الغزو الروسي وذلك مهما
تطلب الامر ذلك واشكر
واشكركم وانني
الصبر بان
نكرز 45 مليار منها
المساعده وان نوقعها
للامن الوطني
من الدول
تقديمي ايضا مساعده اضافيه وتوفير المعدات
التي تحتاج اليها اوكرانيا في الاسر وال
اسابيع المقبله وعلاوه على ذلك
حسين
لها دور كبير في الدفاع عن اوكرانيا
ونخصص اذا اعتمادات الاضافيه
وان همم
الاغتيال الكهربائي وكذلك كل البناء
الاساسيه تستخدم موسم الشتاء السلاح
ان تجعل الاشخاص ايام
وكذلك
ومثال اخر على ذلك لهذه الاعمال الشنيعه
التي ارتكبها الروسيون ضد المواطنين
الاوكرانيين همم هذه الامثله المتعدده
والمتنوعه واننا نوفر كل الاعتمادات
اللازمه ل همم اعاده اذا
العمل وتشغيل الاطيار الكهربائي
وفي التالي
العداله في هذه المنطقه
هذا المساء همم اليهود عبر العالم يحتفلون
بعيد بعيد
حاليا في بلدهم
عن صموده
ونتمنى
بان النورس يحل محل الظلام امل
بانمل
المعاناه بالنسبه
الشعوب والشعب الامريكي الى جانبكم وسنبقى
الى جانبكم دائما وابدا ابدا
ليس لا يطبق فحسب على اوكانيا
لانه اكد على الحريه هذه الحريه التي
ستنير الظلام وشكرا ونحن الى جانبكم مره
اخرى
سوق جزيلا
متواجدين
بشكل امريكا
خلص بقى يا ياسمين
اجتماعاتنا همم
لهذا الامر بشكل جزيلا لرئيس على الدعم
ومن المهمه جدا مساعده اوكرانيا
ونحن نشر
الخطوات التي قطعتها لجمع الحلفاء على
المستوى
بلدان العالم قد اتخذت موقفا
لصالحنا»
وهمم هذه
الزياره تسمح لي ايضا ان الترقيه
بالاعضاء
والهدف هو ان معززه
والثانيه حتى
من اجل حريتها واستقلالها لدي انباء ساعه
فان اداء رئيس بيدا اشار الى حزمه جديده
لتقديم الدعم للدفاع بمثابه مليارين من
الدولارات
وايضا
التزويدنا بمنظومه
زي الشندل
تحدثنا كثيرا مع سيد بيضا عن المراحل
الاستراتيجيه وما نتوقعه بالنسبه لسنه
المقبله فنحن نستعد لكل هذه الاعمال في
السنه المقبله وهذا شيء مهم جدا بالنسبه
لكل الاوكرانيين وانا اتحلى بالامل
واشكركم على ال 45 مليار وهذه المساعده
كبيره هذه
التالي
شكرا شكرا على هذا الدعم كلها همم
مهما كان هل التغير فانني همم اعتقد
بان الجميع يعمل لتحقيق
وخلال كل اجتماعاتنا لهذا اليوم اثرنا
المسائل
المتعلقه
بالاعمال الارهابيه الروسيه وكذلك
علينا ان نحمي السكان
فهذه هي مساله انسانيه بالنسبه لنا اي
الطاقه ايضا هو نحن اااه ارسلنا ايضا الى
العقوبات وكذلك الضغوط همم
ضد هذا البلدي الارهابي روسيا على روسيا
ان تتحمل المسؤوليه كل ما فعلته ضد تناول
ضد اوروبا
مساعدتي الولايات المتحده
السلام
واشكر امريكا على مساعدتها و
على اتباعها لنا في هذه المبادرات
نا ستكون
التفاصيل
شكرا شكرا على
ما قدمتموه لنا
شكرا السيده رئيسنا سما الى بعض الاسئله
وصناعطي الكلمه الى الاريكسيون نيوز شكرا
سيدي الرئيس في22 اييه
حلف طيب
اوكي اوكي
موحدين الى هذه الدرجه لم يتغير اي شيء
حتى الان نحن نعلم ما هي الامور شركاؤنا
من اوروبا
لبلد اوروبي منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ولا نرى اي اشاره الى ان بروتين يريد
تغيير الامور
ونحن نعلم ما هي التحديات وكذلك اسياد
الوطنيه وميثاق الامم المتحده كان بوتين
يعتبر بانه سيضعف النيته لكنه قد
اعطنا قوه اضافيه
ان كان يريد ان تكون اوروبا
نحن نقدم الدعم المتواصل والعالم برمته
يقدموا الدعم لاوكرانيا حتى اليابان
وبالتالي فانني اؤمن والدم
شكرا على سؤالكم ويقول السيده زينكي لقد
سالتموني
لان نفس القيم النصف التفاهم بالنسبه
للحياه
انا اريده هو السلام هذا هو الشيء اهم جدا
فانتم في بلدانكم همم اعتقد
بانكم اتعلمون كل ذلك ان
ينشره
والاطفال
يعيشون بحريه والا يلقوا حدفهم وان
يلتحقوا ايضا بالاجامعات هذا ما اود ان
اودي به وهذا املي بنسبه لكم فنحن نكافح
بغيه
الانتصار والفوز المشاركه ضد هذه الاعمال
البشعه هذه هي الحياه سنفرح وانني
اود ان نفوز جميعا شكرا لكم
لست اقول اتمنى بل اقول انني على يقين
باننا سنفرح جميعا
الولايات المتحده لدعمها لاوكرانيا
وانا اعلم بانهم لم يكون علاقه الحياه
ولما حصل على مساعدته
وسؤالي فنحن ندخل في مرحله جديده من هذه
الحرب ولقد تم الحديث عن طريق الذي يجب ان
نتبعه وكيف يمكننا ان نضع حجزا بهذه الحرب
هل هل هناك نداء
للمفاوضات والمناقشات للوصول الى السلام
كيف يمكننا ان نتساقط حتى
لهذه الحرب شكرا
عظيم
هذا السؤال احيانا اتحدث باللغه
الانجليزيه واحيانا باللغه
الموجوده
في امريكا كان شيء قوي
بالفعل واساسي
في تهديد
من ايضا
بالنسبه لسؤالكم ماذا تريدون
فقط
هذا مفهوم فلسفي اساسا او الحرب
همم بنسبه لنا جميعا
لفانا السلام فقط هذا شيء يختلف بصفه رئيس
السلام لوحده هذا يعني لا يكون
هناك اي تنازل
فنحنناه منهم من هذا الغزو الروسي هذا شيء
كان خطير فانا بصفتي اب
او انتم اؤكد
او ميني باريس
[موسيقى]
من الوالدين الذين شاهدوا ابنائهم يلقوا
حدفهم ما هو ما هو السلام العادل بالنسبه
لهم
الاعتمادات والتعويضات
واي جبر ليس بامكانه
انهم همم يطالبون
بالثار هذه ماساه هذه كارثه كل ما استمر
هذا العدوان وكلام ما كان هناك الكثير من
الوالدين الذين يحبدونها
ولا يمكن ان يكون هناك سلام عادل في حرب
فقدت علينا لسته ادري كيف يمكنني ان اسف
ذلك نحن في البيت ابجد
الكلمات همم الملائمه لكن هذا شيء لا
انسان
اود ان تجيب يقول الرئيس ايضا اعتقد باننا
انه تشاطر نفس الرؤيا
بالفعل فان اكره
الحره والمستقله نريد جميعا ان ان تتوقف
الحرب وكما قلت ذلك سابقا
اذا كان بامكاننا ان نوقف هذه الحرب
اقل شيء من كرامه لكنه لا يفعل ذلك لقد تم
الحديث على المساعده
في صحه المعركه لن تفرح دون مساعده
الاخرين وعندما يكون رئيس على استعداد ان
يتحدث مع الروسي سيتمكنوا بالفعل من ان
يفوز لانه سيكون قد على ساحه المعركه
علينا ان همم
هو عواقب هذا الحرب على اوكرانيا منذ
يومان شاهدتهم بان بوتين صرح وقال بان
المساله هي اصعب مما كان يتصوره كان يفكر
بانه ساء يمزق
وسيمزق كل الحلفاء وان الاوكرانيين الذين
يتحدثون باللغه الروسيه
لكنهم سوف لن يفوز ابدا بهذه الحرب وعلى
رئيس كيف
يدعوه احد لهذه الحرب
اه اه يا ابو سينان
شكرا السيد الرئيس
نعم
[موسيقى]
الاصدقاء
يستهدف الاطفال
لانه يعرف بانه لا يمكنه ان يحتل القران
لم يقبل ذلك ولقد فشل في الماضي ومن اهم
همم علينا يجب ان
يعلمه وان يرى بانني انا والسيد زليسكي
مجتمعين
وانه لا يمكنه ان يقضي علينا
فانني
الى السيد الاسكي ويمكنني ان اقول بان هذا
الشخص هو ما يبدو على وجهه فان السيد
زينسكي هو على استعداد
لضحيه بحياته من اجل بلده
على البروتين ان يعرف بان قد بدلنا قصاد
الجهود اللي يفشل
فيديو
سيستر
مضاد للصواريخ
الدفاع
لقد اشارتهم سابقا بانكم
وما هي الرساله التي تواجهونها الى السيد
البروتين
الابيض معنا ما هي الرساله
وات اي 7
الى بوتين فانني امامكم هنا في الولايات
المتحده مع الرئيس بيضا على هذه المنصه
وانني اعرب له عن كل الاحترام
بصفته شخص وكذلك
ارسال الرسالات
ربما ستتسالون ماذا سيحصل بعد الحصول على
منظومه
الباتريوت هذا
نود ان نقول بان نريد ان نحصل على عدد
اكبر منظومات
نحن في وقت حرب انا اسف لكن هذا هو تقديري
بالنسبه لرئيس
فانه كان
لدينا اجتماع في الرمادي واصبحت رئيس
الاوكرانيا
وارسلنا الكثير من الرساله
كنا له بانه يجب الاحترام سلامه
يجب ان لا تكون هناك حرب فقال لنا لن تكون
هناك هذه الحرب اذا ما الرسائل التي
يمكنني ان ابعثها اليه بعد هذا الكذب فانه
خلاف
دمر حياتنا ويواصل تدمير حياتنا ويمكنه ان
يتجاوز هذه المرحله
فانه
فان هناك همم الشيء همم مهمين بالنسبه
للنهج الذي يتبعه فهو ليس بحاجه الى
الرساله
فهو يريد ان يسرع العالم
ستكون هذا اخر سؤال
عندما بدا الغاز
[موسيقى]
الجهاز بنعم
انني اتفق
ساحدثكم بكل صراحه
في الواقع
روسيا
مقدمه
لاوكرانيا
فكان هناك اكثر من 20 مليار
لمساعدتي في المجال الامني وهناك ايضا
تمنيات اضافيه
للدفاع الجوي وبالتالي فان المنظومه
بكثير من المعلومات من حيث المدفعيات
وكذلك
تكون هناك همم
فنحن لا نعطي كل شيء ذلك لانه هناك حلف
وبتالي في الفكره هو انه علينا ان نزود
اوكانيا بكل المعدات المختلفه مختلفه عن
تلك التي هي في حول ذاتهم لا همم نريد
او بالاحرار نريد ان نعطيه لاوكانيا
حتى يمكنها ان تفوز في صحه المعركه
لهذا سبب
ساعات
ان
معرفه انه يجب ان نوصل مساعده اوكرانيا او
لقد فهم الاجميع
التالي
لا تبحث عن حرب مع روسيا ولا تبحث ان يكون
هناك حرب عالميه ولكن هدف الاساسي
لاوكانيه هو فوزي في صحته المعركه شكرا
لكم
اهتمامكم وكذلك حسنا انتباهيكم
كما قلت لكم
نحن نبقى الى جانبي اوكرانيا